now to an incredibly tragic story
investigators in texas are looking into
what caused the crash that killed nine
people including six student athletes
and their coach authorities say the van
carrying the men's and women's golf
teams from the university of the
southwest burst into flames after it was
hit by a pickup truck the teams were
headed home to hobbs new mexico from a
tournament in midland on tuesday night
janet chameleon has more
two vehicles on fire people trapped
inside the devastating aftermath of a
head-on collision in west texas among
the dead seven members of the university
of the southwest golf teams six students
and their coach
two others including a 13 year old died
in a pickup truck that authorities say
crossed the center line
slamming into the van both vehicles
erupting in flames
it's a very tragic scene
very very tragic we're now learning more
about the victims this is 18 year old
lacey stone cbs station ktvt talked to
her grandmother we are glad that she was
doing what she loves her loss is going
to leave a hole in our hearts tyler
james was driving the van it was his
first year as head golf coach
this is the spot where it happened it's
along a two-way highway with no lighting
the golfers were about 60 miles from
their university
as memorial flowers arrived at the golf
course where the students played the
tragedy hit hard i don't think you fully
recover from a loss as massive as this
megan mooney says the crash happened on
a stretch of road that locals know can
be dicey the highways in the permian
basin are all known as dangerous roads
when you're taking a drive whether it's
your father mother your boss who tells
you to avoid one highway and go down
another two please don't drive at night
on that highway
two college students survived the crash
but their injuries are critical for cbs
mornings janet chamleon andrews county
texas
it's hard to have that much loss at one
time